I agree with you but I also feel like
what we're talking about the energy
thing the problem is with some guys that
do it and we think that they don't have
the energies because they're
inconsistent they're inconsistent for
example
say that again say that again like
inconsistent with energy yeah so like
sometimes they're masculine and
sometimes they're not yeah sometimes
they're really tapping into that
feminine role and you're like you're
turned off because biologically you're
just like as a woman you're gonna look
for that guy who has that energy could
it be could it be based on how you feel
though that day because we feel
differently everything perceive things I
agree